Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir.
Je suis Stéphane Champone
et merci de m’avoir invité à témoigner
de mon expérience de maire.
On est le 7 avril 47, 2047.
Ça fait bientôt 30 ans
que tout ça a commencé.
C'est nos 30 turbulentes.
Alors faut remonter au début
des années 20 pour comprendre.
Vous avez sans doute oublié,
il y avait une grande pandémie
mondiale à l’époque.
Ça peut paraître complètement anecdotique
après tout ce qu’on a vécu,
mais ça a sonné la fin de l’insouciance.
De la mienne en tout cas.
C’est le moment où je comprends
que nos villes marchent sur la tête.
Qu’on est en train de scier
la branche sur laquelle on est assis.
On avait une Présidente, vous savez,
cette écologiste,
qui avait remplacé par surprise
le jeune sortant en 2020.
J'ai oublié son nom.
Bref.
Elle avait la force de celles
qui n’ont pas envie du pouvoir,
mais qui assument leurs responsabilités.
Elle est arrivée à fédérer autour d’elle
et des vrais enjeux de transition.
Mais en vain.
L’homme a besoin d’être
au pied du mur pour agir.
Et on avait encore plus peur de changer
que du climat qui change.
C’est la grande vague de 2025
qui a tout bouleversé.
Il y a d’abord eu ce violent coup
de vent qu’on n’avait pas vu venir.
Puis les images sur nos écrans de la mer
qui engloutit le littoral,
les sirènes, le bruit des hélicoptères,
et finalement les bus qui rapatrient
les survivants.
Alors on a construit des camps,
dans les gymnases, dans les parcs,
pour héberger les réfugiés.
Il y a eu tous ces morts, bien sûr,
ces centaines de victimes
de notre insouciance.
Mais moi, ce qui m’a marqué,
c’est le regard des survivants.
Le traumatisme.
Et le traumatisme, il peut mener
à l’effondrement.
Ou au rebond.
Et c’est ce qui s’est passé.
En 2026, pour les élections municipales,
tous les sortants sont remplacés
par des collectifs citoyens
qui n’avaient pas d’autre programme
que d’être enfin à la hauteur des enjeux.
C’est à ce moment-là
que je suis devenu maire.
Après avoir été désigné par le collectif.
On s’est retroussé les manches.
Pas seulement les élus, les militants,
les équipes de la commune, non non !
Tous les citoyens, dans nos rues,
dans nos maisons, dans nos immeubles,
dans nos façons de consommer,
dans nos façons de nous déplacer,
dans nos métiers aussi.
Dans nos vies finalement.
Alors bien sûr,
il y a eu des hésitations, des conflits.
Des erreurs aussi.
Mais on fait quand même notre part,
on décarbone notre cité,
on l’adapte aux nouveaux risques,
on se débarrasse des énergies fossiles,
on transforme nos modes de vie.
On a même libéré nos rues des voitures.
On a cassé le bitume, on a régénéré
les sols et on a planté des arbres
pour arriver à survivre
aux étés si chauds.
Et on s’est aperçu
que nos rues pouvaient être
des espaces de vie
et de jeux.
Je m'étais engagé à ne faire qu'un mandat.
Alors je laisse la place à d’autres,
mais je ne quitte pas le navire.
Je m’engage dans l’équipe Canopée,
qui est chargée de semer des graines
partout dans la ville.
Je suis l'homme qui plante des arbres.
Pas pour moi,
pas pour maintenant, non, pour les autres,
et pour demain.
Finalement, on a évité le pire :
l’abandon de vastes parties du territoire,
les étés qui tuent,
les pénuries,
les violences.
Et en une poignée d’années,
notre ville a vécu une vraie métamorphose.
Vous avez compris,
je ne suis ni Stéphane Champone,
ni élu local
et nous ne sommes pas encore en 2047.
Je suis Sylvain Grisot, urbaniste,
essayiste, enseignant parfois,
et je continue de me poser des questions
sur ma pratique professionnelle.
Mes débuts d’urbaniste,
c’est dans des toilettes
de bidonvilles de l’océan Indien.
Alors ça semble basique, mais c'est aussi
une tâche vitale et qui rend modeste.
Et puis quand je rentre,
c’est pour participer à l’organisation
de la croissance de nos villes.
Et puis au recyclage de friches urbaines,
jusqu’à commencer à sentir
que quelque chose ne va pas
dans nos façons de fabriquer nos villes.
Dans ma façon d'exercer mon métier.
Alors j'ai commencé une enquête
auprès des faiseurs de ville.
Pour partager leur expérience.
Ça fait cinq ans déjà.
Et je voudrais vous partager
ce qui est devenu pour moi une certitude.
Nous devons changer radicalement
la façon dont nous fabriquons nos villes.
Et vous allez voir,
c’est aussi impératif que joyeux.
En fait, on ne parle jamais de tout ça.
La façon dont on fabrique nos villes.
Pourtant, ça détermine l’existence
d’un toit sur vos têtes
la qualité de l’air qu’on respire
et même le droit pour nos enfants
de marcher en sécurité dans la rue.
En fait, la fabrique de la ville
dicte à la fois
la qualité de notre vie quotidienne
et notre capacité à conserver
une planète habitable.
Parce qu’on vit trois crises -
climat, biodiversité, ressources -
et la fabrique de la ville
au cœur des responsabilités.
Et les problèmes s'accumulent.
La dépendance automobile.
On adapte nos villes à la voiture
jusqu'à les rendre invivables.
Et pourtant, impossible
de s’en passer désormais.
C'est la cause de l'étalement urbain.
Est-ce que vous savez
que nos villes grignotent
l’équivalent de cinq stades de foot
de terres agricoles toutes les heures ?
Toutes les heures !
Évidemment, c’est au détriment
de notre sécurité alimentaire.
Et si on s’étale, c’est bien
pour construire des bâtiments neufs,
alors on consomme des montagnes
de matériaux et on produit des déchets.
Énormément.
Le bâtiment et les travaux publics, c'est
six fois plus de déchets que les ménages.
Et tout ça génère des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre -
près de la moitié de nos émissions -
qui viennent accélérer
le réchauffement climatique.
Et le climat le rend bien à la ville,
il rend les coups.
La ville est en première ligne
par rapport à ces nouveaux périls  :
inondations, canicules, tempêtes…
Les coups vont être plus fréquents,
plus violents,
et ils vont aussi toucher des territoires
qui, aujourd’hui se croient à l’abri.
En fait, on assiste
au dessin d’une nouvelle
géographie des risques.
C’est-à-dire que nos villes
ont un triple rendez-vous pour 2050 :
leur décarbonation, pour faire leur part,
leur adaptation à un climat qui change
et l’organisation
d’une nouvelle résilience.
Pour encaisser les chocs.
Alors, je vous dois la vérité.
Ceci n'est pas une transition.
Encore moins une transition douce.
C’est un changement brutal
de notre façon de fabriquer nos villes.
Ça fait 50 ans
que la fabrique de la ville se consacre
essentiellement à son étalement
et à la construction neuve.
Nous devons décider collectivement
de consacrer le demi-siècle qui vient
à la métamorphose de nos villes.
Et ne nous trompons pas.
On ne peut pas tous
partir vivre à la campagne
et on n’a pas le temps de construire
des villes toutes neuves.
C'est très long de faire la ville.
En fait, 80% de la ville de 2050
est déjà là.
Elle est déjà construite, elle est là,
maintenant, autour de nous.
Alors le chantier est immense,
mais on sait faire, on sait faire.
C’est ce que j’appelle
l’urbanisme circulaire.
Ça commence d’abord par mieux utiliser
nos bâtiments pour éviter de construire.
C'est l'intensification des usages.
C’est un restaurant d’entreprise
qui sert l’après-midi de co-working.
C'est une salle de classe qui peut servir
le soir à une association pour se réunir
ou une chambre vide chez vous
qui sert à loger un étudiant.
C'est aussi éviter de déconstruire.
Parce qu’à chaque fois
qu’on démolit  un bâtiment,
on perd à la fois les matériaux
et tout le capital
carbone qu’on y a investi.
Tous les bâtiments
qui peuvent avoir une seconde vie
doivent être transformés.
C’est une halle industrielle
qui devient un équipement public,
un immeuble de bureaux
qui devient logements
ou un parking qui devient une boutique.
Et puis il nous faut éviter
d'étaler les villes.
Et ça, pour ça, on peut intensifier,
densifier nos villes.
On peut aussi recycler,
recycler des friches.
C’est un supermarché
qui est transformé en usine.
C’est une nouvelle maison
dans un jardin devenu trop grand.
C'est un immeuble de bureaux
sur un bout de parking.
Et puis il nous faut renaturer nos villes.
On a besoin de planter
de nouvelles canopées dans nos villes,
simplement pour mieux encaisser les chocs,
les inondations comme les canicules.
Et on sait faire tout ça.
Rien n’est à inventer.
Le pays fourmille
d’initiatives exemplaires.
Rien n’est à inventer,
mais tout reste à faire.
Parce que ce n’est toujours pas le normal
de la fabrique de la ville.
Alors collectivité, aménageur, promoteur,
bailleur social, architecte, urbaniste,
paysagiste, ingénieur,
chacun doit engager
la redirection de son activité
pour être à la hauteur
des enjeux du siècle.
Élus, professionnels, citoyens,
c’est le moment de passer à l’action.
Alors il va y avoir des crises.
Il va y avoir des renoncements.
Mais aussi plein de nouveaux métiers
aussi utiles que passionnants.
L'urbaniste des temps.
Ingénieur en non-construction.
Promoteur sur toits urbains.
Paysagiste du macadam.
Paysan des villes.
Je ne sais pas si vous avez lu
« L’homme qui plantait des arbres »,
ce magnifique conte de Jean Giono.
C’est l’histoire de cet homme
qui passe des décennies
à semer des forêts
dans des terres inhospitalières.
Et il arrive
à les rendre habitables et joyeuses.
Partageons son obsession
car il nous faut planter
des milliers d’arbres dans nos villes
pour qu’elles restent habitables
et qu’elles deviennent désirables.
Inspirons-nous aussi de cette histoire
parce que le récit de la métamorphose
heureuse de nos villes,
il est encore à écrire.
Et puis prenons exemple
sur cet homme qui agit,
mais en regardant au-delà
de son propre horizon.
Pas pour lui, pas pour maintenant.
Mais pour les autres et pour demain.
Mais…
cette ville qui nous permettra
de passer à peu près correctement
le cap du milieu du siècle,
c’est aussi la ville dans laquelle
on aimerait déjà vivre.
C'est celle où chacun a un toit.
C’est celle…
où les arbres ont remplacé les voitures.
C’est celle où la terre
et les enfants respirent.
Alors faites passer ce message
aussi nécessaire que joyeux.
Et demandez-vous quelles graines semer
pour amorcer la métamorphose
de votre maison, de votre immeuble,
de votre rue, de votre quartier,
de votre ville.
Pas pour les autres.
Pas pour demain, mais pour nous.
Et pour maintenant.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)